hi I'm Sadie and I was a pet care lead
specialist at a pet store for three
years and I have seen some stuff my very
first job was at a pet store and I
worked there for two years we were
fifteen you know so most of the time
people weren't gonna hire us and the one
place that did was this pet store that
was in need of help and I was like
that's awesome I was very excited to get
the job to work with all kinds of
different animals almost immediately I
figured out that it's not what it seems
within like six months I really hated it
you can only clean so much blood stool
before you just say no more I want to
make it very clear that rats are amazing
animals they're sweet they're loving
they're literally like dogs they can
learn their name come to you when
they're called they're tricks
they are awesome I had 12 of my own at
one time I was a crazy rat lady this
story as there always exists there's
just that one little we couldn't sell it
we had to have it in the back room in a
cage because it was so aggressive
this one would literally buy your hand
off so we had to wear these insanely
thick like rubber welding gloves because
she would bite it and eventually bite
through it my position at this time was
to get up really early and clean all the
cages before the store opened so I was
responsible for cleaning her cage which
literally was the scariest thing every
time I did it
so I put on my gloves which mind you it
is very difficult to pick up an animal
big gloves means no dexterity I picked
her up put her in the critter tote
closed the lid and went to clean her
cage when I turned around she was out of
the critter tote this rat she was smart
she was very smart because rats are
incredibly intelligent it is incredibly
hard to get out of a critter tote but
some critter totes have a little thing
at the top and she knocked it up pushed
it out got out which means she was loose
on the floor and I had to pick her up my
heart was racing I was so scared I
couldn't pick her up it's like picking
up a coin with huge welding astronaut
gloves so in this moment I make a
decision I'm going to take these gloves
off
it's the only way I'm gonna get this
wrap I went in for it
grabbed her first try immediately moved
her over to her clean cage and she bit
the hell out of my finger so much so
that it cracked completely through my
fingernail all the way up to the cuticle
it was the most terrifying thing I was
bleeding a lot didn't have to go to the
hospital I ended up being okay rats do
not have rabies
I still love rats just not this one
there was this one time that we had this
male rabbit and this female rabbit they
were having sex but it really didn't
feel like the female rabbit wanted that
so we had to like keep separating the
male rabbit but he was like horribly
aggressive it was like a lot so we had
to put him in another cage the next
morning I went back to clean the female
rabbits cage and we have this little egg
glue thing this little plastic egg loo
that she can kind of play in and go
through I lifted it up and out drops
these baby rabbits and these things are
just born like I'm talking they look
like a naked mole-rat soft look like
little gummy bears with like fur on it
and one of them was dead and so I called
my manager and he automatically just
takes the baby rabbits out of the cage
because for some reason I guess the
female mama rabbit I guess could get an
urge to eat her babies and that happens
a lot so I'm just standing there
paralyzed like the animal kingdom is
about that place we had a king snake
which is something that we regularly
sold but this one in particular was a
little Oh and so bad with the reputation
amongst us coworkers none of us wanted
to be the one to like take it out and
show it so I got asked will you take
this snake out I want to see it I have
this one co-worker who happened to be
working with me at the same time who is
very nice very kind of flirty so I asked
him please do this for me and he did and
he regretted it immediately if you're
watching this I'm so sorry what ended up
happening when he took the snake out is
a coiled and attacked him bit him and
was literally not detaching his jaws
from his hand we started freaking out
the customers were like nevermind I had
to find my manager we were literally
googling how to detach the snakes job
from his hand and we couldn't figure it
out so eventually we were just kind of
like cooing the snake I say we I wasn't
doing anything it was my manager I was
told it doesn't necessarily hurt it's
just kind of like get this out and so
pulling would make it hurt a little bit
so we were trying to massage its head to
release the jaw and it was a very busy
day and poor coworker was having to walk
around with it and like talk to
customers be like look I have a snake I
can't help you after 20 minutes or so
the snake finally released its jaw my
coworker had blood from the bite marks
he was okay he was able to bandage it up
and keep working but after that I never
opened up that cage again to any
customer the snake eventually did get
sold thank God when you're taking care
of a lot of animals at once they're
bound to get sick they're bound to get
messy things are bound to get really
gross so a lot of times I would have to
clean up dog poop and a lot of the dog
poop would be really disgusting like I'm
talking blood in there poop I'm talking
diarrhea I'm talking unknown substances
in there poop so for me it was just like
I could only do so much of it before I
wanted to like puke I remember this one
day that I decided to wear a white shirt
to work it wasn't on purpose it was that
I was wearing a white shirt at school
and then I got to work and I was like I
have no clothes
there was this one cocker spaniel that
was such a sweetheart but so annoying
and that was the one with the bloody
stool that was also a little bit yellow
so that day I wanted to try to like pick
up the poop with the newspapers that was
in his cage he just got so excited that
I was opening the cage and he just jumps
on me and doesn't stop jumping on me so
on me is just like just almost scratches
of yellowish brown reddish poop all over
this white shirt I'm wearing and I just
I just got so mad I just put the dog on
the floor you know normally as a normal
human you'd be like oh well just a dog
don't know what they're doing I was
pissed I was so mad I was at the point
where I didn't give up about animals
anymore I was done I was ready to go
that dog meant nothing to me that dog
might as well have been a giant walking
rat to me because it had gotten its
yellowish brown poop all over me
and I just I gave zero for that one I
was ready to watch it I actually very
much value the time that I worked in a
pet store because I got to help and care
for a lot of the animals I mean a pet
store was my first job I'm glad it was
my last time working at a pet store
because that was a really crappy
experience I think it's an okay job for
young adults I mean you learn a lot if
you get a chance to work at a pet store
I'd say if you wants you definitely take
it but definitely realize that there's a
lot of grunt work that comes with it
including cleaning up poop cleaning up
bloody poop and cleaning up yellow poop
low pay and you might get bit by a snake
but it's a good job if you want to get
an animal from a pet store
do your research make sure that you're
not getting a pet from a pet store that
works with breeders and that you're
exploring all of your options
[Music]